across london's boroughs the fight
against
violent crime is relentless
here in the middle of the day on a
housing estate in hackney
come out now they're chasing a group of
teenagers
suspected of drug dealing
hiding in these bushes officers have
found two of the gang
there's a high gang violence area you
both tried to evade police
for that reason you're both tending for
a search for weapons
these officers are part of the mets new
violence suppression units
based in crime hot spots across the
capital
within minutes of the arrests the
discovery of some key evidence
two male or the males we've chased were
obtaining this bush
and they've been discarding this which
is a rather nasty
machete a combination of last year's
covert lockdowns
and more targeted policing has seen
violent crime fall by around a quarter
over the past 12 months but the number
of shootings in the capital is up
289 incidents where criminals discharged
a firearm
it's thought the suspects are armed with
a gun
we're nearly on scene any direction
metro alpha
the victim says he disturbed two men
stealing the catalytic converter from
his car
when he challenged them he was
threatened with a firearm
as soon as i shouted guys what are you
doing to my car
then the next thing he pulled out was
gone police say the theft of these car
parts containing small amounts of
precious metals
is being orchestrated by criminal gangs
who'll often use violence if challenged
it could have been a completely
different story we've been dealing with
a crime scene
but he's done the right thing he's seen
the firearm he's disappeared and hidden
in a cupboard
which thankfully had keys for at the
scene of the earlier food chase
another deadly weapon and a quantity of
drugs
are now off the streets and out of the
clutches of teenage gangs
it's a little packet there about 30
kills if you can see through the plastic
it's divided into black packaging white
packaging because it delineates
difference between heroin and crack
cocaine on the same afternoon we saw
these officers
disrupting potential violence in this
part of the capital
just a couple of miles away another
teenager
became the latest victim of this
never-ending
cycle of misery stabbed to death in the
street
in the neighboring borough of islington
mark white sky news north east london